and her family recently arrived at the
dardar refugee camp she left her Village
in lower Juba in Somalia when her four
grandchildren died because she had no
food to give them there's a drought in
the Horn of Africa six rainy seasons
have failed
in the last drought in 2011 we were
surviving on goat skin and wild fruits
in this drought we can't even get that
our options are limited this drought is
more severe
more than one hundred thousand somalis
have crossed into Kenya since last year
and they keep coming Aid workers say
they're struggling to give them their
basic needs this is the longest dry
spell in four decades even life-saving
is a challenge for us right now yes we
are providing food wfp wfp providing
food
and we're providing water and sanitation
and that is as far as it goes in medical
and we they have access to Medical
structures but because of the lack of
funding or insufficient funding even
those structures new structures cannot
be put in place so they are overcrowding
the existing structures Ismail Ali
Muhammad is pitching a tent on the edge
of the comp
he has to scrounge to have a roof over
his children's heads
people have been dying the journey from
Somalia was desperate there was nothing
to eat no water to drink I know people
who died on the way
such shelters are scattered across the
area that hosts more than 300 000
refugees majority of whom have fled from
conflict and droughts most of the people
who are coming to this area on the
outskirts of dadab camps are not
registered as refugees yet so they are
struggling to survive they have very
little water and food
the refugees get cereals cooking oil and
some cash every month but the new
arrivals have to wait a little longer to
access the services there's also a
vetting process to ensure those who are
coming in are not a security threat
those like Ismail Muhammad who are
making the journey to these comps say
they just want to stay alive Catherine
zoy Al Jazeera the dab refugee camp